Майже половина українських випускників не знають,
як виглядає Верховна Рада
та в якому місті вона стоїть.
30% не в курсі, що Україна - унітарна держава,
частина якої тимчасово окупована.
Майже половина не змогла скоротити
математичний дріб рівня 8-го класу.
56% старшокласників не знають,
від чого залежить сила вітру,
а 30% не відрізняють
Олександра Довженка від Сергія Параджанова.
Це - лише кілька промовистих результатів цьогорічного ЗНО  -
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання
випускників українських шкіл, які розраховують
на вступ до університетів. У чому причина
таких серйозних прогалин у знаннях майбутнього нації?
Головною причиною і кабмін, і експерти, і батьки-активісти
називають нереформованість системи середньої освіти в Україні.
Системи, у якій досі віддають перевагу не мотивованості,
не критичному мисленню чи індивідуальним потребам дітей,
а слухняності та підпорядкуванню.
Робота вчителів - непрестижна, низько оплачувана
і перевантажена паперовою звітністю.
У школах - ані сучасного обладнання,
ані мотивуючого простору.
А навчальні програми не викликають інтересу в сучасних школярів.
У результаті з року в рік
ЗНО показує приблизно однакову картину -
базові знання випускників українських шкіл
за бажаний рівень. На думку міносвіти,
це одна з головних причин необхідності реформи,
яка вже з 1-го вересня стартує
на загальнонаціональому рівні. Нові "державні стандарти
початкової освіти" почнуть діяти лише для перших класів.
Інша причина поганих результатів ЗНО -
несамостійність та низька мотивація випускників.
Вагомим чинником є тиск батьків,
які за інерцієїю з радянських часів вважають,
що дітям обов'язково слід отримати вищу освіту.
У результаті - 86 відсотків випускників
2018-го року мали намір вступати до вишів.
Хоча такий високий показник
не відповідає сучасним потребам,
бо на ринку праці України лише 40% вакансій -
для людей з вищою освітою
і аж 60% - із професійною.
Уже у 2019-му році з'являться перші результати
міжнародної оцінки якості шкіл в Україні.
Офіційний Київ нарешті приєднався до міжнародної системи PISA,
яка допомагає порівняти знання школярів у різних країнах.
Ці дані покажуть, чи справді рівень освіченості
українських випускників нижчий,
ніж у їхніх однолітків в інших країнах.